détrompez vous ce n'est pas une balade à
cheval en montagne ici les employés de
la ville doivent abattre quelques 4000
arbres infectés par l'agrile du frêne
[Musique]
ce cheval non seulement tire lait bio
mais il permet d'intervenir là où
l'équipement mécanique ne peut pas se
rendre sans endommager la nature c'est
vraiment un projet pilote qu'on fait à
ma connaissance je pense que seule ville
de montréal de que ça se fait entre
dumont québec
je file viendraient vraiment nous
ajouter un outil supplémentaire pour
pour pouvoir opérer dans certains lieux
précis exemple milieux humides de son
veulent essayer d'avoir un risque zéro
niveau des déversements soit d'essence
ou d'huile une opération délicate plus
efficaces jusqu'ici
si le projet pilote est concluant la
ville pourrait mieux lutter contre
l'agrile du frêne dans les secteurs où
la végétation est plus fragiles comme
les milieux humides afin de protéger nos
petits milieux sur la montagne sont tout
petits mais qui sont très importants
parce qu'il ya certaines espèces qui
sont seulement présente ici son
instrument web c'est sous forme de larve
que le coléoptère est le plus nocif en
se nourrissant de la sève de l'arbre
c'est fou comme un aussi petit byte qui
mesure environ
on va dire un trois quart de pause de
long peut tuer un arbre de plusieurs
centimètres de diamètre et tout est mis
en oeuvre assure-t-on pour respecter le
bien être de l'animal c'est résultat
j'avais pas la personne qui le conduit
au fait attention faut il donner des
brides parce que c'est une côte qui
montent beaucoup de documents rares et
la mort il faut aussi c'est d'après ses
cultes et reste à l'achat
si julie marceau radio canada montréal